Raman: Welcome, everyone.
Thank you for coming
to this track
on Android Accessibility.
Let's introduce
ourselves first.
I'm T.V. Raman.
I lead the Eyes-Free project
which basically does
a lot of the accessibility work
for Android.
This is both
framework level work
as well as user space
applications
that we dial up.
It's an open source project,
and you can see the URL
to our project
right on the speaker slide.
With me today I have
my colleague Charles Chen
and Tim Credo.
And during this conference
you can meet the rest of us
from the Eyes-Free project.
Some of us will be
staffing the sandbox.
We have a whole bunch of
exciting stuff to show you
during the next two days.
So let's kick this off
with the next slide
which is the overview
of this talk.
So I'll expl--briefly
at the beginning of this talk
outline what I mean
by accessibility
and motivate why this is
actually fun to work on
in mobile space.
It's not just about, you know,
oh, there are blind users
who need to use the phone.
Let's do some
accessibility work.
Accessibility on Android
is actually
an extremely exciting media
to be working on,
and it's one very easy way
for you to increase
the reach of your applications
in terms of users as well as
how much usage you get.
We'll talk briefly about
what the Android platform
has built-in to make your life
easy as a developer
in terms of making your
applications usable
by the largest number
of users.
We'll then talk about
applications
that work out of the box
and then talk about
how you can go further
if you are doing your own
custom fancy UIs
to add a little bit
of UI magic
that actually then makes
your application
equally accessible
to somebody who's not
looking at the screen
or somebody
whose eyes are busy
and wants to use
spoken output.
And then finally be able
to talk about
what I call
going the next mile
with respect to building
Eyes-Free applications...
which is really about
moving from the domain
of accessibility
as thinking of users
with special needs
to moving to the domain
of usability...
because really building
an application
that works in a large number
of user situations.
During the keynote,
you heard a bunch of
thoughts about
Google's overall vision
for what Android can do
in the home, in the office,
at work, at play.
And as you sort of
think of those scenarios
you'll begin to realize
that building user interfaces
that are maximally redundant,
that are truly accessible,
will really make a difference
in terms of
how your users use
and leverage your work.
Let's flip to the first section
of this talk
which is motivation.
So why is doing accessibility,
or the way I look at it,
building innovative
user interfaces
on mobile platforms
like Android exciting?
All of you know why Android
is exciting
in terms of it being
an open platform
and allowing
a lot of innovation.
But let's just hold one of
those devices up in our hand
and see what all they enable
in terms of sensors
that are capable
of sensing the user's
environment
and consequently
the user's attention
and radius output mechanisms
that are capable of capturing
the user's attention.
And at the end of the day,
that's what is user interface.
User interface is about
capturing the user's attention,
performing some computes,
and capturing
the user's attention
who can read those results.
And your Android phones
are amazing
in terms of what
they can do, right?
You have GPS, you have cameras
so your phone can see.
You have a microphone
so your phone can hear.
It has an accelerometer
so your phone can sense
where you're going.
And with the stuff
that you saw
that's coming down the pipe,
the sky is the limit
because you can basically
connect any access to the app
to the phone.
So when you do that,
the whole user interface
sort of starts disappearing
in the background.
And that's really where
accessibility kicks in
because now you can actually
do more for the user
by the user
actually doing less.
User interaction
is an interesting term, right?
When UI is really successful,
you actually
don't spend your time
interacting with your device.
You use your device
for whatever it was meant for.
And flip to the next slide.
There is a whole other
half of this
in terms of why
accessibility is interesting
which is it can really
change people's lives.
Mobile devices--the kinds
of things we want to do
with Android platform
can change all our lives.
It's not special to somebody
who cannot see
or somebody who cannot hear.
Basically, think of home
at automation and Android.
It completely changes
how you live.
And then ask the question
what does that mean
to users who are typically
early adopters of technology.
And if you look at the history,
people with special needs
usually are earlier
adopters of technology
because something that
you can do without technology,
a person who has
a special need
like blindness or deafness
actually can do it, you know,
with technology,
whereas without technology
it's a lot harder.
So in that context, right,
accessibility
on mobile platforms
is truly life-changing.
And we'll show you
some of these things
that we've built in the last
couple of years.
There's more, obviously,
coming down the pipe.
So that's really what motivates
me and a lot of our team
with respect
to doing accessibility.
And as developers,
as you think about
Android in the home
don't just think
of the blind user.
Think of your grandparents.
How are your grandparents
going to use
these cool things
that we all build?
And guess what.
If the interface you build
doesn't work for
a senior citizen
or your grandmother
because the font you used
was too small,
they're not going
to stand up and say,
"I'm blind.
I'm not able to use this."
They're going to say,
"I can see perfectly well.
It's just the silly font
that I can't see," right?
And so building user interfaces
that work well
is a huge win
in terms of your search.
Flip to the next section
of the talk.
So let's quickly sketch out
what's in the Android framework.
During the keynote,
you saw the Android timeline.
It's amazing how far we've come
with Android as a platform.
And that's true
about accessibility too.
We started working
on Android accessibility
sometime in 2008 and, um,
launched our
Text-to-Speech player
as part of the platform
at Google I/O two years ago.
And shortly after,
we built an accessibility API
right into
the Android framework.
What goes that give you?
So the Android framework
basically isolates you
as a developer
from all the details
of different types of hardware
and lets you focus on building
really cool applications.
The accessibility API
in the Android framework
does exactly that from
an accessibility perspective,
which is where you might
typically think
of accessibility as this
scary, hard problem
that you have to think about--
the blind user,
the low vision user,
the user may be using
a special pedal,
you don't know how
those work, whatever--
it's actually
very, very easy,
and that's the reason why
we put accessibility
into the framework.
It's there on every phone.
It's there on every
shipping form since Android 1.6.
And what the API does for you
is that if you code
your application
using standard Android
view elements,
your application will work
pretty much out of the box
for a blind user.
You have to do a few things
to pay a little bit more
attention,
which is what
this talk is about.
And as you do that,
you can sort of see
what else we've built
in the last couple of years.
The big change last year
in Android
from an accessibility
perspective
was pluggable
Text-to-Speech engines
which, again, is in the spirit
of the openness
of the Android platform.
But what that gives you
is that you called up
an application.
You used the Text-to-Speech
that's on the platform,
and it sounds okay.
Instead, they've added
[indistinct].
But your users can then
go to Android Market
and build--buy better voices
for a few dollars.
And they buy that voice,
they install it,
and guess what.
Suddenly your application
starts sounding
really, really nice.
And it's win-win
for everybody
because all the applications
that talk sound better.
This means people
buy more engines,
and the more text-to-voices
there are
obviously there's more incentive
to write talking applications.
Flip to the next line.
So accessibility,
as I said,
is built into the platform.
And as a developer,
you're probably
asking yourself at this point,
"So what's the hit,"
right?
Every one of us,
we are building applications
on mobile devices,
that's the first thing
we ask--
what's the hit
in terms of performance?
And the answer is zero.
The reason the answer is zero
is because
of how it's designed.
The way we surface
accessibility and user
is via the settings menu
where there is
an accessibility option.
And even though accessibility
is bundled on every phone,
nothing happens
until you check that.
So you have a user
who needs that service.
He checks accessibility,
and he activates one or more
what we call
accessibility services,
which we'll talk about.
So an example of an
accessibility service
might be TalkBack which is
an open source screen reader
that my team wrote.
Now, what happens when a user
checks the accessibility option
and activates
an accessibility service
is that the platform
then starts raising
what we call
accessibility events
as the user interacts
with an application.
So you're a user now.
You're moving through the radius
controls in your application.
Magically,
your application starts raising
accessibility events.
And the payload of that event
tells the accessibility service
what's going on.
So then the accessibility
service then stops speaking.
And because of this,
you actually work very cleanly
in the Android multiprocess
architecture
So your application
runs on its own process,
there is an accessibility
manager that sits between you
and the accessibility
services that are listening.
Application raises the
appropriate accessibility events
through the platform API,
goes across
the accessibility manager,
lands in the accessibility
service
which then does
the speaking or talking
or vibrating or in the future,
Braille or whatever else.
So that's sort of
the overall architecture,
so the main takeaway here
is that it's zero impact
in terms of performance.
Uh, flip to the next slide.
As I said,
the way a blind user
would use your application,
for instance,
is by sort of
linearly moving
through the radius controls
in your application.
The way you move through
the controls in your application
are because Android phones
come in many shapes and sizes,
with the trackball,
with the keypad,
with the D-pad,
and increasingly with
swipe gestures on the screen.
So one of the first things
you need to pay attention to
is that the traversal order
in your application
is sort of sensible
when you're sort of moving
through it linearly.
However you do it, right,
whether you do it
through the touch-screen
or whatever else,
a user who cannot see
has to sort of
go through all of your controls
at least once
in order to get
to where he wants.
So making that traversal clean
and making sure that
everything
that needs to be
interacted with is focusable
is one of the first things
you need to do.
And the other very small
thing you need to do
is make sure that your controls
are correctly labeled,
especially if you're making up
your own controls.
With that, let me hand over
to Charles
who can sort of start diving
into more details
on some of what
I just covered.
Chen: Thank you, Raman.
So I'm going to talk to you
about TalkBack.
Raman: We're not letting you
off that quickly.
Chen: Well, we're not
done yet, so...
Okay so I'm gonna talk
to you about TalkBack.
And TalkBack
is a concrete example
of an accessibility service.
As the name implies,
TalkBack talks back to the user
and lets the user know
what's on the screen.
So it's our built-in open source
screen reader for Android.
It ships standard
as part of Android,
and it's open source,
so people can learn form it
and extend it.
And so TalkBack,
the way it works is,
as Raman mentioned before,
a traversal through the controls
is very important
because there are
no special commands
that the user
has to learn.
All users simply just navigate
through the interface
and use the interface
just directly by scrolling
through it,
clicking on things
with the trackball and D-pad.
And as the user
moves through things
and generates system events
such as selecting events,
clicking events,
so on and so forth,
these events get raised
at the platform level
and TalkBack
receives these events,
processes them,
and then speaks the answer
to the user.
So the user knows that, hey,
I now selected this list item
or now I've clicked this button
and activated something.
or I've checked
this check box.
So it's very easy to use,
very simple,
very straightforward.
But it's very important
that the user can get to the
controls
so that they can navigate
and hear what's going on.
Now, the other thing is
this model is really nice,
but there are some times
when you don't want to
just speak whatever
is happening on the screen.
So a very good case of this
is how many of you here
have used Voice Search
in a search with Google?
Cool.
That's a lot.
So as you know,
it's almost magical, right?
You take out the phone
and you speak a query
and there you have it,
you know.
Google does a search.
It recognizes
what you're saying,
and it gives you
the results.
Now, the problem is
if you're running TalkBack
and if TalkBack
just announced everything,
you would hear
something like...
"voice search started"
and then you would be doing
a voice search
on voice search started,
which is probably not
what you were aiming to do.
So instead,
in special cases like this,
we can actually filter
on the package name on the event
and we can say, hey, well, maybe
instead of speaking it
we should just play
on intercom
and let the user know
when they can speak
rather than, you know,
get into a recursive loop
where we try to
recognize ourselves.
Raman: And this feature
in the Accessibility API
where you can filter
by package name
is actually a very
interesting hook
for those of you who are
developers in the audience.
Because let's say
you sort of try
a very popular application
with TalkBack.
And you decide, okay, TalkBack
works with that application.
But I think I could do better
by making this application
talk really intelligently.
And you decide to
develop such an application.
So you take
the full application,
and you develop
a Full Talk application.
You can actually have full talk
filter events by package name
or respond to full events
and then pass the rest on
to whatever other
accessibility service
the user is using.
And what you will get is
a market application
called Full Talk
that your user can pull down
and use it with this really
popular application Full
and get really intelligent
feedback from that application
and still enjoy the benefits
of the platform access
that TalkBack provides.
So it's a very,
very useful feature.
It's something that
I believe we need to
document better and evangelize
better with developers,
because I personally
would like to see
those of you who are developers
start writing
those type of apps.
Because they are
really easy to write,
and you can provide
real value out on the platform.
Chen: Absolutely.
And the other thing
is that we very recently
added a new feature,
and this new feature is
support
for a talking keyboard.
So this means that
from now on
when you use the latest
version of TalkBack,
if you upgrade for Market,
you'll get a version
that comes with a soft IME,
and you can use that IME,
and it'll actually
speak back to you.
So you can type
just on a touch-screen.
In addition to that feature,
it also comes with
a virtual D-pad,
so for devices which don't
have a physical D-pad,
you do have a virtual one
that works
in pretty much the same way.
And I'll actually
be demonstrating that
a little bit later.
Finally, we realize that,
you know,
it's very important
to have access
to all the controls
on the screen,
whether or not
they're focusable,
and we are working
towards that.
But in the meantime,
it is very important
that you can
traverse and navigate
through all the controls.
So I've talked a good amount
about accessibility service,
a concrete example
in TalkBack.
I'd like to focus on what
makes a view accessible.
So as Android developers,
what can you do
in your applications
so that all the views
that you present to the user
are easily navigable,
easily understandable,
easily usable.
So Raman actually spoke to
a good amount of this stuff
already
in his earlier statements about
how it's very important that
we have focus on everything,
that you have a, you know,
have a good traversal order
and also the importance of
labeling all of your controls,
especially things like
image buttons, right?
Because if you have
an image button
and it's just
this image button,
well, that doesn't
really tell you too much.
Five image buttons, right?
Which one does what?
So it's very important that
you clearly label your controls,
make sure everything
can traverse well.
And finally, Raman also
mentioned this a little bit.
He talked about how you can
extend things
through the accessibility
service.
But you can also extend
the views themselves directly.
And the way you extend
the views directly
is to simply override
the dispatchPopulate
AccessibilityEvent.
So this is the event
that gathers the accessibility
events from its children.
It will go through
all of its children nodes,
asks its children nodes
when it should speak,
and it combines this.
So if you're making
a complex widget,
you can override this method
and then you can provide
your own way of speaking.
And I'll go into more detail
on that a little bit later.
So let's look at how you can
create really accessible UIs.
So if you came to this talk
hoping to see how difficult
it was to create something.
You were expecting, you know,
oh, wow, now I get to solve
a really hard problem.
I'm sorry you're gonna
walk away disappointed,
because most of the hard work
has already been done for you
in the framework.
So if you just stick
to standard views
that are
part of the Android SDK,
you'll see that most of
the heavy lifting is done.
If you use a text view,
if you use a list view,
things like that,
they just work out of the box.
And there's really
nothing special
that you need to do there.
If you do want to do something
interesting visually,
such as, you know,
restyling a button
or restyling your list views,
those are really just
style attribute changes,
and they won't have any adverse
effects on accessibility.
The thing to be really
careful about here
is just to make sure that,
again,
that you're labeling things
correctly
and that, you know, especially
things like image buttons
and other controls.
Raman: And this is the thing
important to carry over
when you build
your own custom views.
Because one of the things
that Android does
really cleanly
in the view layer
is the separation of layout
from like the logic
of your controls.
So the radius layout
.XML files
that you are used to writing
won't help you
quickly move your UI
among different devices.
So then you do a custom
control of your own.
Make sure
that you design it
where all the layout stuff
is abstracted out
into the command file
because they will both
help you take your application
to multiple phone factors
and also make the accessibility
part really easy.
Chen: Thanks, Raman.
So, uh...now...
if you wanna do something
a little bit fancier,
if you're trying to modify
an existing view
and perhaps make
a composite view,
then in such cases
what you can do is...
again, most of the work
is done for you.
You may want to do
a little bit of touch-up
to make the spoken feedback
better and more intelligible.
But generally,
it just works.
So as I mentioned earlier,
the Android framework
will go to a view
and then go
throw off its children.
So if you just have
a composite view,
it's just going to take off
its child views
and then composite the result
and speak it back to the user.
Now, sometimes that's not
necessarily
the best speaking order,
and I have an example
later on
that shows how you can
correct for that.
But if you do want to
correct for that
or enhance
the spoken feedback,
then what you need to do
is just override
the dispatchPopulate
AccessibilityEvent
and reorder things.
Finally,
in a most extreme case,
if you wanted to create
your own view from scratch.
So this is--if you just
took the base view class
and you said, you know, I'm
going to do everything myself,
if you go that route,
that's really the only route
where you have to do
some serious work
for accessibility.
Because if you go that route,
then you do have to write
your own dispatchPopulate
AccessibilityEvent
and figure out
what you need to fill there.
Also in both cases
of composite views
and, you know,
complete custom views,
you'd need to make sure
that your traversal order
still makes sense
and that you don't end up
trapping the user
inside a control
such that they can't get out
and get to the rest
of the application.
So let's look at an example
of how we can make
a custom view
more accessible.
So for this example,
I'm going to use
an actual product that we have.
This product is called
Google Authenticator.
It's an open source
application.
It's designed to generate
one-time passwords.
So this is for
users who are interested
in doing a two-step
authentication process
where their first step
they type their password,
and for a second step,
there's an application
that they run on their phone.
And they click on "get code."
It gives them a number,
and they type it in.
And that's an additional
physical token
to ensure that the user
is who they say they are.
So we have this open source
application,
Google Authenticator.
It's on Google code.
And all of the code
that I'm showing here
is actually liked
to that code repository,
so you can look at it
afterwards
if you're interested
in seeing the details.
What makes this really
interesting
is that there's a view here
called a UserRowView.
And this UserRowView
is a great example
of a composite view.
It's a composite view
that contains the user name,
the generated passcode,
and an interactive control,
a button,
that the user can click on
to generate a new passcode.
So let's look at what
the default behavior is like.
So I'm actually going to go
to a demo here.
Let me just get to
the right screen.
It works better
if I plug in the audio.
Okay. So I am going to show
two versions of Google
Authenticator.
First I'm going to show
the unoptimized one,
and then I'll show
the optimized version.
Are we good to go on the demo?
Cool?
Okay.
So I'm going to start
the unoptimized version first,
and you'll hear
how it sounds.
I may bring up
the virtual D-pad
so I can navigate
through that.
voice: Navigating.
Clicked.
charles@charlesisawesome.net
underscore, underscore
underscore, underscore,
underscore, underscore get code.
charles@charlesisawesome.net.
937,49 get code.
Launch your
Google Authenticator.
Chen: Okay. So let's go
back to slides.
So if you look at this,
right,
that kind of works.
But it was kind of
a clunky experience.
It wasn't very pleasant,
right?
You ended up hearing
my username first,
which is, you know,
if there's only one user,
why would you want
to keep hearing that, right?
And, uh...and then
you hear the number.
But the number was spoken as
one really, really big number.
So imagine you were trying
to type this into a form field.
It's going to be
pretty difficult.
So can we do something better?
The answer is yes.
And the way we do something
better is we override
the dispatchPopulate
AccessibilityEvent,
and we do it in such a way
that we take advantage
of the semantic meaning
behind that control.
So we present it
in a better way.
So here's how you can do it.
So as I said,
what you need to do
is you need to override
this event,
and then you reorder things.
So the most important thing
here is actually the passcode
that you're trying
to let the user hear.
So you should
speak that first.
You should also break it up
so it gets spoken as digits
instead of asked
one huge number.
And then in case the user
has multiple user names,
you can put the user name
at the end
so they hear it
as a confirmation that
it is for the account that
they think they're listening to.
So let--
Raman: In terms of extrapolating
what Charles showed there,
this is something that I
personally describe as
leveraging the semantics
of your application
to produce
good spoken feedback.
So you're taken back into
your own development mode.
for instance, if you're writing
a shopping application.
Visibly on the visual screen,
it might make a lot more
sense for you
to show the product name,
some other description of it,
and then the price
over on the right inside,
because the eye can quickly
scan to the right inside.
You'll probably discover
that if you're doing
a good spoken interface,
speaking the price
and the product name first
is probably more important
than a long description
or, you know, the bunch
of reviews there are for it.
So this technique
that he showed you
is going to be applicable
in a lot of places.
And just because
you need to do that
doesn't mean
that you have to do
all of the work needed
for accessibility.
You just need to populate
that one event correctly,
and you're good to go
with the rest of the framework.
Chen: Thanks, Raman.
And, in fact, it's so easy
that we can fit the code
for doing this
in just one slide.
And the cool thing about
fitting it in one slide
is afterwards,
it's actually
still readable code.
So let me go to that.
So first off,
you just start off
with the standard boiler plate
that you're going to override
dispatchPopulate
AccessibilityEvent.
Nothing fancy there.
And then here you see that--
well, I'm looking at this,
I'm looking at the pin text.
That's the code that gets
spoken to the user.
And you'll notice I have
a If statement here.
So basically, if the user
has never clicked anything,
then it's basically
just all those underscores.
So instead of saying underscore,
underscore, underscore--
you know, that gets
really annoying, right?
Instead of saying that,
we can just directly
tell the user, "Hey,
click here to get a code."
And if they've already
gotten a code,
then we go further
and we split up the number
into individual digits
so that when it gets
spoken back,
it will definitely be
spoken back one digit at a time.
Also we talked about
reordering things.
So notice how the digits
came first
and then at the end,
we're appending the user name
so that it's a much
smoother entrance.
And finally, we just package it
into the accessibility event
and we return it,
and that's it.
We're done.
So let's see how much better
it sounds now
with the optimized version.
So we're gonna go back
to a demo.
Ready?
Okay.
So I'm going to now start
the optimized version.
And this is still a version
that's actually on Android
Market if you download.
So you hear this.
voice: Clicked.
Get code
charles@charlesisawesome
charles@charlesisawesome.net.
Chen: Okay.
voice: Launch your
Google Authenticator.
Chen: So let's go back
to slides.
and, in fact, let's go to Raman
to talk about
well written apps
are accessible
right off the box.
Raman: Thanks.
So let's talk about applications
that are accessible
out of the box,
because we at Google
do the work
on the framework.
We do the accessibility APS.
My team even does
some Eyes-free applications.
But the nice thing is there's
Android Market out there
that however billions
of dollars that you heard,
and it's really, really nice
to be able to go to Market,
grab an application,
and be able to use it.
So what's involved
in actually doing that
and how much success
do you have.
So years ago growing up,
shortwave radio
used to be my hobby.
And, you know, technology
is interesting, right?
Today shortwave radio
is old-fashioned technology
that nobody touches.
We have these nice
smart phones.
But yet, we all still listen
to radio stations
from around the world.
So radio stations
continue to be a hobby.
So I wanted to show you
one of my favorite applications
that I just worked out of
the box for the most part,
and I pulled it from Market
about six months ago.
It's called TuneIn Radio.
It allows you to browse radio
stations from around the world
and play with
with one click.
The application
as really accessible
because it was built with,
you know,
platform-level Android view
hierarchy elements.
So you could basically use
TalkBack, scroll through it,
listen to
the radio station names,
browse by location,
do searches, click, and play.
And there was one minor
accessibility problem.
As I prepared this talk,
I was hoping that
that problem would persist
so that I could show all of you
how easy it was
to fix that problem.
In the process
of preparing the talk,
I wrote to the developer
and said,
"Hey, by the way, look,
you do have this little
problem in your application,"
and the problem was
that his play/stop button
was an image button
that didn't have a label.
Now, I liked the application
so much
that I basically learned that
that particular image button
was the play/stop button
and was happily using it.
But I told the developer,
you know,
this is going to be
really easy to fix.
I said, "We going to to talk
about your app.
Is it okay with you?"
and he said,
"Oh, yeah, go ahead,
talk about my app.
I've already fixed it."
That's how much long
it took him.
Basically within 24 hours,
the fix was on the Market.
Um, Charles, quickly,
we want to show them?
Chen: Yeah, sure.
We'll show the app.
Raman: So notice that this app
works dearly well
in multiple modes
of interaction.
And that's important,
right?
It would be extremely ironic
if, in order to listen
to the radio,
you first had to
sit down in a chair,
hold your phone
in both hands,
and squint at the label.
That'd be stupid, right?
This goes back to
make your application
such that it's usable
in all the context
that your user wants to be able
to use it in--
jogging, running,
driving a car.
Cooking lunch.
Whatever, right?
So just take a look at how easy
this application is to use.
Chen: Okay. So I'm going to
scroll for some categories here.
voice: Music.
Local radio.
Search image button.
Browse.
88.5 KQED-FM.
Public forum.
KQED.
Raman: So your local NPR station
is probably faster
to launch with this
than with your
physical radio,
which is how it should be,
right?
In general, if you actually
do the numbers,
you will find that
if it takes your user
a minute to do something,
he's going to do it
a certain number of times a day.
But if it takes him ten seconds
to do that same thing,
the number of days--times
that he will use it in a day
will go up
an order of magnitude.
We all wear wristwatches--
well, at least my generation
of people wear wrist watches.
Charles doesn't wear
a wrist watch.
But see how easy it is
to look at the time
on your watch, right?
And that's how easy
you want tasks to be,
because when they are
that easy,
you do them
a lot more often.
Flip to the next
line of of the talk.
So you want to pick up this,
by chance?
Chen: Sure. So can we
go back to slides?
Thanks.
So I want to talk quickly
about how you can test
for accessibility
to make sure that your apps
are actually
gonna work well.
And the nice thing is that
on Android,
it's extremely easy
to simply test by doing.
So what do I mean by that?
Well, you don't need to buy
some fancy screen reader
or spend lots of money
because Android comes with
a screen reader built in.
So all you really need to do
to test it for yourself
to experience
what your app would be like
for a user
that's on a screen reader
is to go into settings
and turn on TalkBack.
It's really easy to do.
I can even do it right now.
Why don't we actually
just do that?
So can we switch to demo?
So all you really need to do
is on your home screen
if you simply go into
settings...
man: Demo's up?
Chen: Yeah. Demo's up.
And you go into...
voice: Settings.
Chen: You go into
accessibility,
and you just need
to make sure
that accessibility checkbox
is checked.
voice: Accessibility settings.
Chen: And the TalkBack
is checked.
And once those are checked,
then voila--
accessibility
is up and running.
That's just how easy
it is.
Raman: And you heard
a number of things today
during the keynote
about how Cloud really makes
for a lot of interesting
experiences
when you get in your device
because you sign in,
and all your goodness
comes through.
Accessibility
is part of that story.
So for instance,
if I grab a new device
and sign in,
it actually starts talking to me
because the cloud knows
that my device has talked to me.
The moment that accessibility
option gets checked,
everything talks
and by default
we can actually turn
that on from the cloud.
Let's go to the next
section of the talk
where I'd like to talk
briefly about...
sort of moving over
from the domain
of accessibility
and special needs
over into the domain
of user usability
which really starts touching
a very large proportion
of your users.
It touches both your users
with special needs
and also realizes
that all of us are special
at some time or the other.
There are many times
of the day
when your average user
is functionally blind.
There are many times
of the day
walking through a noisy
airport hallway
or, you know, walking through,
you know, a crowded hallway
in Moscone Center
after the keynote
where your user
is functionally deaf, right?
So there are these environments
where you really want to start
building your application
to leverage
that environment.
So let's talk briefly
about that.
So there are three
sort of things
that I personally like to
point developers at
in terms of what it means
to build mobile applications
that are truly usable
in a large variety of scenarios.
The first is leveraging
the fact
that these devices have
so many sensors and actuators.
It's something I alluded to
right at the opening
of the talk.
So basically, the more
that the device knows about
the current context,
the less you as the user
have to tell it in order
to complete the task
that you're trying to complete.
At the end of the day,
that's user interface.
User interface isn't about
clicking fancy colored buttons
or, you know, making things
go boink, right?
It's about rapid task
completion.
And rapid task completion
is really the next bit,
which is, as I said,
minimize user interaction
by leveraging the fact
that the device knows
a lot about you.
These things are called smart
phones for a reason, right?
It's not just a marketing term.
There are two reasons why
your device is a smart phone.
It's smart in the sense
not because it has
a gigahertz processor.
It's really smart because
"A", it has a large number
of sensors and actuators
for sensing and interacting
with the physical world.
And it's connected
to the cloud.
However fast your phone's
processor gets,
the cloud is bigger,
right?
The cloud,
in terms of intelligence,
in terms of your
user context,
in terms of what you did last
on your browser,
what you did last
on your tablet,
that context is huge.
And as you leverage it,
you basically get
the user interfaces
that disappear
into the background
and let you complete
your task.
And that's the best thing
you can do for accessibility.
And finally
voice recognition, right?
Speech recognition
is sort of a technology
that my friends in the
technology world say is coming.
It's come.
In fact, it's arrived,
and it's arrived so ubiquitously
on Android
that you don't even
think about it anymore.
Three to four years ago,
writing
a speech application
required you to be
a real rocket scientist,
and I kid you not.
When I was working in speech
research many years ago,
most of the people
who worked in speech research
eventually became rocket
scientists on Wall Street.
because it was sort of
the same mathematical techniques
that was used
in both places.
Today you don't need to be
a rocket scientist
to write a voice recognition-
based application
because on Android,
it's one API call away.
Recognition happens
in the cloud,
and your application
just gets intelligent.
Uh, pick up the next slide.
Chen: Sure.
So how can you obtain feedback
in eyes-busy environments?
Well, you can leverage
built-in Text-to-Speech APIs
to generate speech.
So for example,
if you're jogging
and you wanna, you know,
fiddle with your music player
and change tracks,
do you want to stop jogging,
you know, do this
and try to shade it
and see what track
is playing?
No. You wanna be able to keep
on going with your workout
and just keep jogging, right?
So here's where you can use
the touch screen
and you can use spoken feedback
to tell you what
the next track is.
And you can just stroke it,
and it should play, right?
We actually have--
I was talking about that...
RockLock.
That's another open source
application we have.
Great for accessibility.
But actually,
it's great for everyone.
So when you have Eyes-Busy
interface,
that's...
that's a good time to use it.
The other thing is,
of course,
you can use haptic feedback.
So going back to RockLock
example, right,
as you switch tracks,
you get a little vibration,
a little buzz that lets you know
that, hey, something happened.
So that, in addition
to an auditory cue
and the fact that music
has switched,
that really sort of hammers
the point home.
It almost feels like
you're using
a physical--
physical buttons
to drive the player.
So what can we do to minimize
the interactions
needed to perform a task?
Raman was touching on several
of these points earlier.
Well, Android devices
have many eyes and ears.
It's able to sense things,
it knows where you are,
and it's got many ways
of catching your attention.
So for example, you know,
it can flash the screen at you.
It's got the LEDs.
It's got haptic feedback.
It can speak to you.
It goes on and on and on, right?
Raman: And with Android
at home,
it can turn off the lights
in your rooms
and put you to sleep.
Chen: Exactly.
Or turn up the lights
and wake you up.
With really loud music.
So user interaction
is really about
communicating
the user's intent to the device
and obtaining feedback
from the device.
And so I encourage
everyone here
to think about how you can
best leverage these
to minimize explicit
user interaction
and just make things work
for the user.
Raman: So We'd like to bring
another colleague up here
for a couple of demos
for Intersection Explorer
and walkie-talkie.
As Tim comes up--
Chen: So--so Raman,
why don't you talk a little bit
more about these applications
as we resolve
the network issues.
Raman: So while we set the phone
up on the network...
so Internet Explorer
and walkie-talkie
are two applications
built on top of Google Maps.
And these were built for
a very concrete use case.
About two years ago,
I got dropped off by
the Google shuttle,
and it was a new driver.
So he got it exactly right
except that he dropped me
on the opposite side
of a very small street.
And I did not have
walkie-talkie at the time.
I did not have Internet Explorer
at the time.
I knew my home neighborhood,
and I still walked
in the opposite direction
from home
and actually spent
about half an hour
wandering around,
trying to get back home.
And so we came back
and started building
a couple of applications
with, at the time, the G1.
We ultimately built a simple
diverse geocorder at the time
that would actually
tell you where you were.
And then about a year ago,
Google Maps
launched walking directions.
Walking directions
are really nice,
and it actually works
out of the box
with Google Maps
and TalkBack.
But now here is the bit
about building a user interface
that minimizes
user interaction.
The default maps interface
actually has the flexibility
of picking either
driving directions
or walking directions.
That's only one gesture
that I did not want to do.
We also said...
for the blind user,
not only do you want to speak
walking directions,
but you actually want to say
what you're passing.
You ready?
Chen: Yeah. So I'll use Tim's
because he has FreeG...
Raman: All right.
Coming up.
So Tim will take over
from here
and sort of talk you
through this as he demos it.
But it's a very, very
useful application.
It's one of the--
Chen: Whoo-hoo.
Whoo-hoo.
Wifi.
Raman: Wifi.
So that's great.
So demo...
Chen: Yeah.
It's up and running.
Thank you.
Credo: Um...
so Raman has been saying
these smart phones have so much,
so many sensors in them,
so in a way, it's a...
when you're really designing
something for accessibility,
you can actually go
a bit beyond
what's in the system level
and take advantage
of all these different modes
of interaction.
So this, as Raman was saying,
Intersection Explorer
is a map-type experience
for someone who's blind.
And it uses sort of
a virtual D-pad...
gesture interaction.
And...
Charles...
Chen: Oh. I think we need
to make sure
this is plugged in tightly.
Oh, can we--
[overlapping chatter]
Chen: Could you please make sure
the audio is on?
It is? Okay.
voice: Northeast along
Howard.
Move 49 meters to left
onto New Montgomery St.
from Howard.
Northwest along New Montgom--
North.
Northwest along Howard Street.
East. Southwest
along Howard Street.
Move 49 meters
to left onto Hawthorne
from Howard Street.
Credo: So you can see
as I'm using this,
I'm controlling it
via adjusters,
and these are adjusters that are
gonna be independent
of wherever I start
on the screens
so if you can't actually
see the screen,
it's still just as easy to...
voice: Southwest along Howard
south--
Credo: to navigate here.
And the feedback is...
[indistinct]
and so in particular,
we're paying a lot
of attention here
to how we're speaking
each intersection
so that you get some cues
that make sense to you
about where you've
explored to...
voice: Northeast along
Folsom street.
East. Southwest along
Hawthorne Street.
East. Northeast along--
moved 136 meters
to second--Saint crossesFolsom
Folsome street.
Raman: So this year it's hard
for you to experience
the haptic feedback
it's providing.
Next year, we'll make
the chairs vibrate.
But in the meantime,
you can believe me
when I say that as he moves
his finger over there,
you can actually feel
each street.
Chen: Or if you can't wait
until next year,
go catch us
in a sand booth.
We'd be happy to let you
try it in person.
Or even better, just dial it
on your phones, right?
Raman: It works on
many device, so...
Chen: So let's switch
to the conclusion slide.
Raman: Right. So conclu--
to sort of wind up, right?
A simple takeaway
from this talk
is that just as
five years ago
if you had to build
a mobile application
that ran on a 100 million
devices,
it was a huge,
hairy task.
What Android has done
as a framework
is made that trivial.
Where a high school student
today can be thinking
he'll learn Java, pick up
the tool they're speaking,
write an application
and get it running
on 100 million devices.
Similarly, accessibility
traditionally has been
a huge hairy, scary
bugaboo thing for developers
where there is a lot of
awareness among developers today
thanks to things like the
Americans with Disabilities Act
and the various regulation
around disability,
so people are aware that
accessibility is important.
But it's always been
a scary thing.
A simple takeaway for you
from this talk
is that accessibility
on Android is not scary.
It doesn't require
an expert.
It only requires you
to use the bits in the framework
that are already there
and test for it.
And finally,
focus on usability.
And focusing on usability,
every one of us,
when we sort of sit down
at a keyboard
and develop these applications,
there is one thing
and one thing alone
that drives us.
What drives us is getting
a lot of users out there
to benefit from the insights
we have,
from the flashes
of intuition we have,
from the creativity we have,
right?
As software engineers,
we--
just as a painter picks up
an easel and a bunch of oils
and creates something beautiful,
software engineering is
as much an engineering science
as it's an art.
when we are building something,
we are creative.
And the most satisfaction
you get from the creativity
is by getting your apps
to be used by
as large a number
of users as possible.
So from an accessibility
perspective,
when you sit down
to write your application,
think of the widest number
of use case scenarios.
Don't limit your user base
to somebody who's got
20/20 vision,
can touch the screen,
can, you know,
speak and move,
can do everything
and is sitting on a chair
looking at the screen.
Design for
the broadest use case
and speed up past completion.
And by doing that,
you will not only make
a huge impact on users
with special needs...
What you will inadvertently
achieve with that moon shot
is that you will vastly
increase your user base
and find that your users use
your applications a lot more.
We can start taking
questions from here.
We'll put up a slide.
And I think that there's
a microphone up there
that you can walk up to
for questions.
Chen: There are actually
two microphones.
Raman: There are two
microphones.
All right.
man: Hello.
I had a question.
So most of the focus
of this talk was
on vision-impaired users.
I know, obviously,
hearing-impaired
and movement-impaired users--
well, I guess is--
is mainly the focus with Android
on...on the vision-impaired
use case,
is that like the biggest
hurdle to jump, or...
or what's the other focuses?
Raman: So great question.
To summarize
for the video recording,
the question was
is Android Accessibility
focused on blindness
and low vision
or are we also paying attention
to other disabilities?
The answer is we are definitely
paying attention
to other disabilities,
and as the question
is summarized,
a lot of the focus
right now
is on blindness
and vision impairment,
because that's where
the biggest challenges are.
We have another talk later
today from our team
that sort of gives
an eye-level overview
of all the accessibility
stuff we are doing.
And you'll see some very
innovative users of Android
for helping users
with hearing impairments
in that talk.
And do come by our sandbox
where we can talk in more detail
about the various things
we are doing.
So absolutely Android
accessibility in general
and accessibility at Google
is not limited to blindness
or vision impairments.
It's a very broad idea.
Chen: Also, just to add on
to that point...
several Android devices
are hearing-aid compatible,
so it's a hardware issue,
and several of them
do have that.
And in addition to that,
there are several
open source projects
aimed at other impairment.
So for example,
there's a university project
called Tekla.
T-e-k-l-a.
And it's using
the Android IME
because it's an open,
flexible framework
and letting you control that
though a Sip-and-Puff
interface.
Raman: So they are doing it
for Sip-and-Puff.
They are trying to control
wheelchairs with Android,
all kinds of cool stuff.
man: Okay, great.
Thank you guys.
Good work.
Chen: Question?
man: Yes.
Hi. I have a question
about where to get support
as a developer if I'm writing
an accessible application.
I had an issue a while ago
where a text view
with the password tag
just simply would not show up
whatsoever with the
accessibility.
I couldn't find out where
to get support.
There is nothing online
for accessibility whatsoever.
I'm wondering if you guys are
gonna put up some documentation
somewhere about how to resolve
common issues
or just ways to better write
accessible apps
because all the documentation
I got was "use the content
description label."
Chen: So a couple things.
First is I invite you to look
at links up there.
We are improving
our documentation.
There's also an eyes-free
user group
where you're more than welcome
to ask questions.
We regularly read these posts
and respond to them.
And finally, if you're
interested and you have time,
I'd be happy to talk to you
offline after this
to look at your specific app
and issue.
man: All right,
that would be good.
I think actually I looked
at the eyes-free project before,
but it actually said
"If you're a user, post here.
If you're a developer,
post on Google Groups."
Raman: That is probably over
a year, year and a half ago.
If you sort of look at the
overall velocity
of Android development,
eyes-free work
and accessibility work
has probably matched that.
So you may be pleasantly
surprised.
Of course, documentation
is never perfect.
And we can always write more.
But right now, I think about
a month or two ago,
we actually added
an accessibility section
to the Android dev guide.
So you should probably find
a lot of the basic answers
in there today.
Chen: So the link is up there.
Please talk to me afterwards.
man: All right, thank you
very much.
Chen: Yes?
man: Yes, Fred Giff
from Open Intense.
My question goes
in a similar direction.
Do you have some guidelines
or some strategy
how to make your accessible
applications
more accessible or discoverable
by the user?
Do you suggest to add a certain
tag to your market description?
So that people can find
your app.
Raman: To summarize
the question,
are we planning to show
developers
how to add more mark up
to the applications?
Was that the question?
man: Um...well...
how find the people
my application?
Chen: Oh, discoverability.
man: Yes, discoverability.
Chen: So please advertise it
on the eyes-free group
if it is something that
is accessible
and would be helpful
for this user base.
Raman: In typical Google
fashion,
a lot of this has happened
bottom-up.
I think one of the easiest ways
for users who need accessibility
today to discover applications
that are accessible
is through a website that I call
Android Access.
I think that it is actually
allowing to post reviews
of applications.
So you can actually go
to that site and see
what people--users who need
accessibility
think of particular
applications.
And in the last month,
I've actually discovered
applications from there
rather than actually
pulling down applications
from market
and playing with them myself.
So somebody else is actually
doing that work already.
It's crowdsourced, right?
It's a whole bunch of users
doing it.
So definitely do that.
Google for the Android
accessibility.
Do a search for Android
You will find a lot of resources
that are grassroots
and actually work very,
very well.
Chen: Yes, ma'am?
woman: I just wanted to clarify
the previous question.
He was asking, "Can you flag an
app on the Android market
"as 'We're
a very accessible app'?"
Raman:
That's a great question.
So "Can you flag a market
application
as an accessibility
application?"
It's a feature request
that we've received.
that I, myself,
have raised.
I don't know at what point
something like that
will become available, but
that's great feedback to hear.
We'll definitely take it back.
Chen: All right.
Any other questions?
Anyone?
Okay.
Well, thank you.
Raman: Thank you for coming!
Chen: And please attend
our next talk.
[applause]
Raman: Look forward to seeing
you guys in the Sandbox.